thank you
donate
Tomatoes foreign
foreign
is a very important day for the Republic
of Moldova and for the friends and
partners of our country that are coming
to the Republic of Moldova tomorrow we
are going to say with very big proud
welcome Europe to in our house
the whole Europe is joining in nebulbaka
a nice Village from our country to
discuss about security energy and about
in Europe that is better connected and
that is more prosperous it is an honor
for us to be the host of the summit of
the European community of the European
Union with a participation of 50
Presidents and prime ministers and high
officials of the European Union
has many friends that are close with us
and that are supporting us in our
aspirations that are joining our
citizens to build a Moldova that is
European at home
presence of these leaders in our country
in the presence your presence is
a message a very clear message that
Republic of Moldova is not alone
it is not alone neither our neighbor
Ukraine which for over one year and
three months is standing against with
heroism and courage Against The Invasion
the Powerball invasion of Russia the
fact that the second meeting of the
political community of European Union
takes place at a distance of 20
kilometers from the border with Ukraine
is a proof of unity and stronger Unity
on the European continent
the three countries joined their forces
and United in order to protect the right
to life and freedom over people of the
people of a country our citizens joined
their forces also in order to be to
stand for Ukraine and to say very
clearly that our people want to live
with dignity at home and to decide by
themselves their fate the citizens of
the Republic of Moldova
despite or no matter what is their
ethnicity or mother tongue or political
Vision want to have a safe life in a
peaceful country and free one this thing
was set very decisively at the meeting
we had European Moldova on May 21 2023
over 80 000 people
came to the general assembly and over 50
people from over 50 cities in European
countries said in one single voice that
the place of Moldova is in the European
Union
and the authorities from kishano are
undertaken daily efforts in order to
carry out reforms and fulfill those nine
conditions of the European Commission
by improving the Justice sector by
fighting against corruption and
organized crime by strengthening the
administrative capacity of the country
and resilience of the country thank you
very much to European commission to its
member states and to you Dia Ursula for
the support and openness you have thanks
very much for the budgetary support that
helps us overcome easier in these
difficult times we are welcoming the
decision of European Union that was made
yesterday to sanction persons who are
threatening their democracy and
stability of the Republic of Moldova the
restrictions imposed will prevent the
their attempts and the attempts of the
other people with similar intentions to
destabilize the country and to block our
future
the our connection to the European Union
is strengthened by more and more
agreements and mechanisms to which the
Republic of Moldova is adhering on
Europe day we became members of the
mechanisms for interconnection of Europe
which would help us increase investments
in the modernization of roads in the
energy sector and the digital one to
improve our infrastructure and to
increase the trade with European Union
countries
in several hours we are going to launch
here in Kitchener also the partnership
mission of the European Union in the
Republic of Moldova within the security
policy and defense policy common policy
which is going to help us strengthen the
security sector in the country and this
is concretely a partnership with
European Union this is exactly how we
get closer to Europe This is How we get
integrated in the European Union how we
help each other during difficult times
and celebrating the successes of each
member and we are closer to the dear
people from our life wherever we are I'm
really happy to announce that our
country and the European Union
designed together today a new agreement
and in particular the agreement on the
liberalization of roaming tariffs the
agreement provides for the decrease of
tariffs for roaming Services starting
from January 1 2024. thus when we go to
the European Union when we travel there
we'll be able to talk to our families
that remain at home more often and
cheaper
thank you very much Mrs president
for trusting us and having confidence in
the Republic of Moldova the place of
Moldova is in the European Union the Our
Generation has the task to bring Moldova
to the European family and to bring
European Union home
I have full confidence will succeed
thank you
thank you very much president Sandu dear
Maya it's wonderful to be back in
teaching now indeed moldovar is this
week the political heart of Europe
and I think it's natural and
self-explaining that the second Summit
of the European political Community
takes place in Moldova
because your country embodies Europe's
core values
that is solidarity
which you showed towards the Ukrainian
refugees
resilience
which you show to Russia's blackmail
and unity
which you show to link your destiny to
the European Union
it was very moving to see a sea of
European flags
here in kishinao streets last week
and my message to the people of Moldova
is that we stand by you
we support you
every step of the way on your path to
the European Union
and today I'm glad to announce a new
support package for Moldova with a
double objective
we want to support you to address the
impact of the war on your doorstep
and we want to bring you closer to the
European Union
this package has five very concrete
initiatives
first indeed we will lower the roaming
charges between the European Union and
Moldova
today the Telecom operators signed an
agreement which I warmly welcome
to lower the data and voice roaming
starting next year
and I think it's a very good step which
will benefit the people and our
companies because indeed roaming cheaper
roaming is good for the business it is
good for the people this is our
experience too it connects people
literally
the second point is we will provide
additional economic support
since October 2021 the European Union
has provided more than one billion euros
to moldovan this includes 300 million
euro in macro financial assistance for
this year
now on top of this
we're stepping up support with our
economic and investment plan for Moldova
our initial Target was to reach 600
million euro of additional investment
the good news is that we will be almost
tripling that amount indeed with the
additional financing that we will
mobilize
we can now leverage to 1.6 billion euros
and that will bring great opportunities
for Maldives companies so a direct
investment into the economy
the third strand of the package support
for the energy sector you mentioned it
the energy crisis provoked by Russia is
still hurting Moldova
we are here to support you both in short
term and with long-term measures
for the short term we will provide more
than 100 million euros to cover the
immediate needs that is for example to
help the vulnerable people and
households to make residential buildings
more energy efficient and of course to
prepare for the next winter
I am very pleased that Moldova is
participating in our European Union's
gas purchasing mechanism this is a
platform where all the member states
are aligned and we
go to the market the gas market to have
the best offers Moldova is part of this
gas purchasing platform and it is
already a big success
because we could see that 80 of the
volumes of gas that you have requested
via this platform have already been
matched this is very important because
it's better prices and it's reliable
suppliers
I think this will help mold about
security of gas supply enormously
and looking at the long term for energy
we're working together
in a way that we will fund projects to
facilitate more of us integration into
our European Union's energy Market
so we will invest in renewable energy
which is crucial to produce dependency
on fossil fuels
and we will work on electricity
interconnectors with two new high
voltage power lines between Moldova and
Romania
finally a brief look at the transport
Networks
for this we will make available 50
million years for the rehabilitation of
railway lines
as part of the European solidarity leads
now my fourth point is on security and
resilience
earlier this month the European union
agreed a 40 million euro Patrick package
for Moldova to finance military supplies
and strengthen your Armed Forces
including through Technical Training
now we want to further increase the
European peace facility support to
Moldova
we clearly see Jeremiah how Russia is
trying to destabilize Moldova with
hybrid actions so we are stepping up our
support
to increase your resilience against
Russia's hybrid threats
we've just launched a partnership
mission
to provide you with strategic advice on
crisis management and hybrid threats for
instance cyber security and countering
foreign interference
my final point is about moldova's
reforms
to advance on the EU path
I can clearly see that you are making
big progress this is good to see and
it's amazing and we will support you to
advance even faster
and this is why we will now
significantly increase the number of
Staff of our EU delegation in Kishi now
it's basically to support you in the
development of the reforms but also to
help you to build the administrative
capacity that is necessary
let me end Jeremiah by thanking you for
hosting us here in Kishi now
the presence of 50 European leaders 50
heads of state and government right now
in Moldova in Kishi now gives a very
strong message
Moldova is at the heart of Europe
Moldova is Europe
and today and tomorrow the whole of
Europe is Moldova thank you very much
dear colleagues from the Press we will
accept one question for each of the
officials
picture of support from Moldova
president Sandu has said that moldova's
democracy specifically it's democracy
needs protection
by the EU against Russia is that the
sort of protection that the EU is
willing and able to provide
the protection we want to provide to our
friends in Moldova is manifold
so we have discussed for example that
Moldova needs economic support that is
protection if you have a country where
the economy is stable and thriving
of course it's for people also to see
that there's progress and that democracy
delivers
I give you an example last year I have
not forgotten the difficult situation
you were in when Russia started to
Blackmail Moldova with its huge
dependency on Russian fossil fuels
now we've been working hard and I really
comment Moldova you went through a very
difficult time but today
you've gotten much more Independence
much more self-confidence you are able
to purchase the gas on the world market
you are able to invest in Renewables so
this is a classical field in the economy
for example where protection is through
investment in the right cause
the second element is for example the
economic and investment package now
that's good for the small and medium
companies and the business here in
Moldova
and of course we also support you and
protect you in how to fence off
the multiple threats you're suffering
from Russia what cyber security for
example is concerned or what hybrid
threats are concerned and here with a
lot of advice because we also have the
experience we want to strengthen
your resilience as much as possible
but the most important I think is
to support and facilitate the accession
process towards the European Union
so and here we've been working
intensively together I really commend
you for the progress you've made perhaps
here for you how the process works we
will have an oral presentation of the
progress in a couple of weeks but very
important is the written report that we
will have in October the commission
issues the written report and this is
then the decision
um making
um document for the European Council
which will then decide on the progress
in December but I can only say from my
experience in the cooperation with you
that it is amazing to see that despite
all the pressure moldova's advancing
rapidly and with high quality
foreign
is are you expecting any die Russian
diversions during the summit considering
that the Republic of Moldova is provided
now with electricity only from
transnistra and if there are any
diversion plans foreseen and how secure
is our our
ayas that is considering that in the
past we have had some Rockets from
Russia falling on our territory I would
like to inform you that we have a
generator and even if there were some
problems with the power supply these
problems would not affect the summit
works because I'm repeating myself we
have the generator we have secured it
and as regards the protection of the
airspace as we have announced earlier
it is protected our space including we
the support of our friends
everyone is safe in the Republic of
Moldova
and dear colleagues after the joint
picture please ensure the corridor
the event is over
foreign
how is going on the recovery plan with
Italy and also they planned that Europe
has to help country with more migrants
is going to find an agreement to do you
think in Europe yeah but this is a press
conference on Moldova so very specific
thank you
um